- We're seconds away from season two
of the Drew Barrymore show.
They say go big or go home
but we're gonna do both.
Fire this thing up
(car roaring)
(car hooting)
because there truly is no place like home.
I'm going coast to coast from New York
to California, and everywhere in between
to celebrate all our hometowns.
So let's do this from the
place I was born and raised.
Hello, Hollywood.
This is The Drew Barrymore Show.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello, hello.
Welcome.
I can't believe we're here.
This is all for you guys
and it means so much to all of us
because you are our very first
in-person studio audience.
(audience cheering)
We didn't have the privilege
of that in year one.
And what a way to kick things off.
We are here in my hometown of Hollywood
(audience cheering)
at the iconic Paramount Studios.
My grandfather, John Barrymore, shot here.
(audience cheering)
I love that, hello, hello.
(upbeat music)